好 半個月前我們還講說
光學股大概是台股盤面上
最整齊最強的
但是大力光自從被銳銀調降之後
大魔也來了
今天玉金光一樣也跌停
光學股的災難什麼時候會結束呢
因為前景還是很看好啊
他們有講CPO確實有做
只是現在的估值比較高
但是危機何時可以變轉機
大家都在等
再來台電明明就是持續的資本支出
台電不漲 廠物好累喔
可是常窩的單已經滿到爆炸了
OK 我先看一下
因為我覺得現在比較麻煩是
真的沒有量
聽說你今天本來要減碼對不對
對 後來呢
因為拉了一個滿長的下影線
所以我還可以等待一天
你又忍住了 對
可以等待一天
就是我還是按照我的這個節奏
就是目前來講
但我是維持在這個七成以上的資金
是 對
因為從大概8月這一波過來以後
基本上一直是站在大概季線之上
所以大概我這個步調是沒有變
那這一波下來
本來今天是確實啦
一根下來
當然我們就開始想說
大概要不要降到大概五成嘛
對不對
我們講說加上五到七成
因為今天月線有差點守不住
對 對
可是後來這個在
其實在10點多大概這個
這個下影線就很明顯
對 所以我稍微忍住了一下
那看明天就是說
如果還是維持在這個
所謂的月線左右
我可以做一個等待
那因為現在來講
就是月線跟季線
是一個比較糾結的狀況
其實之前來講
當然就很容易做切割
那現在來講
其實現在你發現說
離這個季線也不遠
所以有一點危險就是說
如果直接灌破這個四萬五以下
那當然就是
有可能落入比較偏空的一個
而且可能月季線都下彎
對 所以還是得要靠
一些量
那我覺得說
當然現在來講
大家會再觀測一下
現在美國的一個狀況
至於說整個大盤之外
就是個股
那個股上次我們大概談大力光
大力光
那當然我那時候有講就是說
基本上我並不是不看好它的未來
未來是看好
問題是它在近期
它的本業的狀況是比較下滑
所以我對你說
如果近期比較下滑的情況下來講
它的本益比基本上是比較偏高
因為這一波來講
上來講已經拉到這個
大概7000多嘛
因為上個禮拜你來
你說你會先稍微避開
對 會避開
好 先避開了
好 又一根跌停板
對 那因為它避開以後
它當然被降頻了對不對
那降頻又開始就有一個
沙盤的一個動作
不過以技術面來講
我大概講的是
技術面的一個看法就是說
因為其實這裡是一個前高
對 前高你引過來以後
這個就是一個
第一個破高的一個起漲點
也就是說這一波事實上
在創高的一個位置點呢
就是它的一個
從5000拉到將近8000的這個
大概第六支的一個漲幅
那現在呢你發現說
這一波被調了以後
速度很快
它大概不到兩周的時間
現在已經拉到
也跌破6000了
那我倒覺得說
如果以這根拉過來
按理講說
這個起漲點
基本上就是等於
這裡的一個支撐點
也就是說上次的一個
這個壓力點突破
壓力變支撐
所以我倒覺得說
以現在來講已經很貼近
這個所謂的支撐線
那目前來講
這些線看起來大概在
大概5300、5400左右
所以我倒覺得說也很貼近很貼近今天的一個價格所以我覺得說在這裡如果你有的人當然是不要這時候去做一個急殺動作反倒在這裡它有可能整理過後
再拉上來的時候
拉上來因為它離月線
還有一段滿長的距離
大概有接近大概6千7左右
所以大概在6千5百多
所以我倒覺得說如果是想要出
你可以貼近月線的時候
再來做決定
好 但是想要買呢
我覺得是可以貼近這個
支撐點的時候
支撐點不破對不對
如果破還是要注意
破基本上就不要去做了
破就不要碰喔
至少說在這邊有時候下引線
或者在這邊之間就是
拉上來收紅那當然是最好
這裡還是可以做一個短朵
是 投信其實就賣了三天
投信對 又回來了
投信前面大概一賣光
又開始稍微沉絕一點
不過今天反倒是外資買了
好 外資
一邊出報告打發一邊賣
今天投信等於是把前面又賣光
是 國聚你也在500塊救過
可是它比較不正
國聚現在來講
因為整個我覺得被動元件來講
還是得要看國聚它的一個動向
核生堂當然基本上都還滿強
可是我覺得國聚呢
基本上我認為說
大概在530左右
我認為是一個這個箱形的
一個低點 底部
所以我會在這個箱形的低點
跟所謂的這箱形的高點
大概670左右
这个区间值蛮大的
大概只有150块
所以我会觉得说
只要接近500多一点
实际上我最近做了好几趟
好 因为云翔哥
对 短冲战神可以在区间做
可是上次你有提到
如果要形态完成
最好还是要有WD
但现在看起来打不起来
WD本来我们讲说
在这个位置点来讲
应该是先打到这个位置
看能不能
先打不上去以后
反倒它变成一个
比较长距离的一个箱形
那现在箱形来讲
那你就贴个箱形来做也可以
對 也不一定要說真的要
等到這個WD突破
這個頸線再來做
我覺得這裡還是可以做一個
箱形的一個整理
好 那就適合短區間操作囉
另外一個是日月光
那日月光基本上
我們上次講的時候
當然它箱形那時候
HU要突破
計畫突破
對 其實就一個人被幹下來了
那我倒覺得說你可以看
它現在供的是所謂LEAP
我們講說這一塊就是
所謂的AI的這個晶片
HPC 還有HBM
都是很高階的一個晶片
所以這一塊它毛利
基本上是很高的
那這一塊來講
就是說光Q4來講
認為說因為這樣子
所以它毛利可以拉到近30%
比以前來講是好很多
加上說CPU這個是
還沒有切進來
所以如果說CPU
在2027年 2080年進來
也無所謂
因為它本來這一塊
本來就沒有估到說
CPU進來的部分
所以總體來講
我認為說
它足跡成長的情況下
目前來講
它還是我覺得是偏低
好 月光算是没有什么
利空冲击的
但是就是股价牛皮
所以我觉得说600
600以下大概
680左右到650
刚好是一个箱形一样
580到650
如果你要等到箱形突破
当然也可以
那我觉得说在这里
如果你认为说
它值得投资
我倒觉得说是在这里
说箱形的接近底部
跟箱形的高部这边
还是可以做一个
所谓的箱形整理
因为这段没有量
大概这种箱形的机会
就比较大
好 三大龙头股
云翔哥现在只要来
就继续帮我们的追踪
那另外这个是
比较中小型的股票加金
最近开始活泼起来了
因为今天来讲
大家知道很强的就是
这个所谓的功率元件的部分
尤其今天来讲像这个德维
是直接所涨亭
那强貌基本上也非常强那主要在MOSIFI这一块来讲我们讲说它竟會漲價效應很明確也就是說第四季來講應該整個市場來講認為說這些股票
當然它的業績來講
會直接拉上來
可是大家就沒有想說
基本上這些股票的上游
累積的部分
什麼累積
就是碳化系
對不對 SIS 碳化系
我覺得說以這樣的情況下來講
就是說它應該不會只有這樣子
今天來講也有表態
可是我覺得表態
它的量基本上是有供起來
沒錯
那供起來之後我認為說
以降的話這個箱形已經突破了
已經突破
對 已經突破了
那已經突破的話
我覺得說這個只是一個
突破的一個開始
如果整個這個所謂的
公立半導體
公立元件有整個拉起來
那基本上我認為
它的機會點還滿大
對 這也可以注意
因為量能比較小的情況下
中小型股可能就比較
會是盤面的重點
大型股剛剛講到
都比較在等待這樣
這次我覺得是可以注意
好 那再来就是说
我们来看一下
就是以台积电来讲
确实来
因为台积电最近是比较软一点
是
对 可是台积电也没有跌下来很多
也是
就在这个区间来讲
就是稍微有点震荡
对
可是相对于说台积电们
这些所谓的这个很强势
不是很强
就是业绩很强的
业绩很好
这个所谓藏物的部分
我觉得说有点可怜
是
对 那为什么讲可怜
就是说目前来讲台积电也讲说
它在两奈米三奈米
就是扩产啊
对 扩产
就是扩产
就是说9万片
2.9万片要到11万片
这其实是增加蛮多的
那3.9万片
18万片到21万片等于是
增加幅度其实都不小
那以这样来讲
就是说它的资本租出预期来讲
也会跟着增加嘛
是
所以在这里面
就是厂户的部分我们看一下
我这里大概有把它做出来
就是说以亚翔 汉塘 樊宣
这三个是最主要台积电的一个供应
那这一面你会发现
以亚翔来讲
也就是說以Q1跟Q2來比來講
它的成長率大概有74%
也就是說今年大概估到65塊
這估值來講應該是可能
因為現在來講
它持續月還是在創高
所以如果以這樣的情況下
它今年的本益比大概11倍
它已經回到以前設備股的本益比了
完全不像AI時代
明年大概是88塊的話
就只有8倍
怎麼低成這樣
其實也不只這樣
你看像漢堂 帆軒
基本上他們本益比都不高
都好低
對 本益不高
另外來講就是說
设备来讲像星云万论
基本上这个就稍微比较高一点
对高一点
原因是当然大家认为说
它是一个材料
耗材的部分
跟一个主要设备的部分
好那不过总体来讲
你可以发现
我就以这个盈利率来算
算什么东西
其实你可以推估它的载手订单
那载手订单来讲
现在亚翔载手订单是4400亿
那如果你推算4400亿
你是乘以这个盈利率
大概就知道它的收益
大概是會落在哪裡
那以這樣來講
我就大概可以抓一下
就是凡軒來講
事實上你會發現
基本上它是一個比較
偏多的一個走勢還在走
其實這一段漲很多
對 已經漲很多了
所以一旦被市場認同
就漲這樣
其實它的本益比
也是比較高
可是基本上我覺得
法人大概著墨比較多
所以這一支來講
基本上我覺得說
目前來講
維持在這個位置
那我覺得如果是
以它這樣來講
那相對亞翔就有一點
被委屈了 為什麼
因為總體我們剛講
載手訂單4400億
其中光上半年的接單量
就接了3000億
那這3000億來
是不是怕他蓋不完
第三季我覺得說
他基本上有一個優勢
他不是只有台積電所以這3000億裡面他有講這90%左右大概是在東協所以东协就是新加坡那新加坡里面盖场是盖了哪些场包括美光
对不对
所以美光里面的HBM
也是在这个评估里面
对不对
那当然台积电
在新加坡也有
所以就总体来讲
就是说它还有其他的一些客户
基本上在这一块来讲
占比也很高
所以我认为说
以这样来讲
就是它分散性
其实还不错
那以它的一个
这样的一个状况
就是说未来来讲
就是说如果8月的营收
是有年增到41%
前8月大概63%
那明年来讲
这个量当然就会攻进来以后
就因为明年的成长性
可能会超过3% 40%都有可能
因为今年这EP值是65块
明年大概是大概88块
那以这样来讲就是说
目前这个落点来讲
它反倒是拉回这个
这一波大概股度的一个位置
它快要回到股災那裡去了
怎麼會這麼慘
對 因為之前我們在Parkest有講
就是說
你還記得
六字頭的雅箱
我說六字頭
基本上我就
就一定會去買這樣的一個
比較偏利去買這樣的標的
因為對它來講
它相對於說
它這個載手電量這麼多的情況下
它的安全性還是比較高
那現在又回到這個接近的威士典
我認為說
如果你把這個做一個區間
因為上一波等於彈上來很快
對 那一波我們講完大概在700
直接就彈到800度
这个区间还蛮大的
对 所以就是说
你以这样的一个状况来讲
是我认为说
如果你依财报跟未来的题材性
设定一个自己可以接受的
一个入场券的位置点
那基本上我觉得说
你可以先介入一点
那介入一点以后
就可以设一个所谓的区间操作
就是这个区间
那基本上有上海
也许我就可以做一个
区间的一个停力可以先走
这样子
所以也可以做一个来回的一个操作
总之我认为说
以这一波如果量
还是持续维持在比较低量的情况下
那区间操作的方式呢
我觉得是有机会再持续这样子
好 对
因为刚刚亚翔的话
我们可以看到
其实那一波急沙的时候
他业绩超级好
所以这边有量在接
对对对 没错
可能反而现在再去掉下来
就没有量了
对对对
所以为什么呢
因为最主要是整体的一个市场的量
全部萎缩掉了
那现在萎缩掉以后
大家其实上对于这个路场来讲
就有一种就是停滞的一个状况
所以只要这个市场的量起来
自然这一量
当然它会更上来
那我觉得说
以这样子的位阶来讲
但我自己认为是比较安全
好 非常谢谢云翔哥的解析
好 虽然今天的量
对于喜欢看到放量的操盘手来说
是比较无聊的
但没有喔
他看到很多东西
都可以看出一朵花来
例如说我们看到大力光在急跌
急跌就酝酿后续
有可能止跌反弹的契机了
国具虽然区间比较小
但是现在在区间下缘的话
来回操作也是一个方式
以及日月光
因为业绩到第四季肯定是成长的
横盘整理就等它做一个突破
另外我们看到像常务工程类的
实在是不用担心明后年的订单
甚至本一笔都压到快要十倍以下了
虽然现在量能比较小
好像市场比较不关注
可是对云翔哥来说
这就是现阶段最安全
最保底的一个选择提供给您
好 今天非常谢谢三位来到现场
虽然量能比较小
可是呢
盤面上卻有非常多的故事在酝酿喔
有时候压缩到极致
就是后续可以期待的第四季行情即将展开
当然这个阶段我们要锁定自己最有把握
最有新鲜的产业喔
那也希望今天的理财导演秀
对你特有帮助喔
明天再会了 拜拜